nos piden determinar el conjunto
solución de este sistema y nos dan 3
desigualdad es una manera de abordar
esto es graficar el conjunto solución de
cada una de estas desigualdades ver
dónde se traslapan y esa base otra
región
en el plano coordinado xy que es la
solución del sistema graphic hemos para
empezar que igual a 2 x + 1
esta desigualdad incluye esa recta y los
puntos que se encuentran sobre ella la
ordenada al origen es 1 así es que
cuando x es igual a 0 y es igual a 1
aquí la tenemos y la pendiente es 2
avanzamos 1 a la derecha
2 arriba avanzamos ahora 2 a la derecha
vamos a avanzar 4 hacia arriba vamos a
graficar otros puntos por acá este es un
punto este es otro punto aquí tenemos
otro punto más y un último punto ya
tenemos puntos suficientes para trazar
la recta ésta viene más o menos así esa
es la región para igual a 2 x 1
ahora para allí mayor igual que 2 x 1
vamos a tener que incluir todos los
puntos que están arriba de esta recta
para cualquier x igual
2 x 1 va a estar sobre esa línea pero
los valores de jay mayores a estos
también son válidos
el conjunto solución de esta desigualdad
es toda esta área que tenemos aquí toda
el área arriba de la recta toda el área
arriba incluyendo la línea recta pues es
una desigualdad mayor o igual que esa
región es esta desigualdad que tenemos
hagamos la segunda desigualdad la
segunda desigualdades y menor que 2x
menos 5 ahora para graficar que igual a
2 x 5 quizás ya te diste cuenta que
estas dos rectas son paralelas tienen la
misma pendiente así es que 2 x 5 el
orden al origen es menos 5 aquí tenemos
menos 1 - 2 - 3 - cuatro menos 5 aquí
está el ordenada y la pendiente es 2 es
una desigualdad estricta no incluye a la
recta la pendiente de la recta es 2 la
pendiente es 2
aquí tenemos varios puntos y como la
región no va a incluir a la recta
podemos dibujar la entonces con una
línea punteada así es que
el conjunto solución para esta
desigualdad son los valores de y que son
menores a 2 x 5 si los valores de la
recta son los 10 que son igual a 2 x 5
la solución de la desigualdad son los
valores de ye que se encuentran por
debajo de la recta así es que va a ser
esta región que estoy sombreando aquí
antes de graficar la última desigualdad
pensemos en esto para que algo cumpla
con estas dos desigualdades tienen que
ubicarse en ambos conjuntos solución
pero como puedes ver los conjuntos
solución no se traslapan no existe un
punto en el plano xy que esté en ambos
conjuntos los conjuntos están separados
por esta tierra de nadie entre estas dos
rectas paralelas así es que no hay
solución la solución es el conjunto nulo
más bien conocido como el conjunto vacío
también se escribe así dos llaves con
nada adentro no hay conjunto solución o
la solución del sistema es el conjunto
vacío podemos hacer x mayor que 1 está
es x igual a 1 ponemos una línea
punteada porque no está incluida en la
desigualdad y esta es la región donde
las x son mayores que 1 no hay puntos
con estas tres al mismo tiempo esta zona
aquí es la solución de las dos
desigualdades de abajo esta zona de aquí
cumple con las dos desigualdades de
arriba pero no hay valores que cumplan
las tres desigualdades conjunto vacío